shop shop shop okay oh come from people
of my weed Oh villages oh they got one
of our villages we should we should not
kill him
oh it's satisfying them mmm
we gotta save one of the villagers do
they turn our villagers yes yeah they do
so we have to save him but shop shop
shop
everyone except villager for dropping
iron oh my god all my things are
breaking wait I cause distraction with
this hey over here
Hey Hey look at me all right this way
and following me he is an epic yeah it's
so up thank you jack for the help my god
no problem okay I mix a mix think okay
we caught him okay nice nice I'm making
I'm making sword you do day that's a
pretty good mom trap actually hey buddy
hey buddy got him all right we got to
make sure this son doesn't are there's
actually more Oh don't walk over
potatoes I know I got to end his life
deserved hey hey hey hey hey God good
job hey hey hey hey hopefull do bead I
don't have any more material dang it
what are you trying to do where you have
to make him a prison before the night
comes Sun comes because I in the night
don't sing and the last kill you get
copyright
our farm is doing great
our farm is the best firm I've ever seen
so if you make ayran fence
chip-chop Iren bar it actually it
actually is better
oh god it's are just about to come we
need to fence him up bro I'm doing it do
it better
boy I can't do right next to it do you
do bee do bee a speeder uh no sir
he's speaking language of goods SPEA dad
yeah cover over entirely yeah he needs
to be completely covered I made this
mistake before we take care of our
people Jack we don't just let him rot if
you turn into a zombie
I would cure you I made a little tiny
prison for a tiny little boy Oh tiny
little bug a tiny bit a prison
you stay in there little boy shop shop
son it's about to come up so we'll see
if this works okay cool hopefully the
wood doesn't breathe some light in no no
that's that's how that works no wood no
good cool now we can look at him and
spit out I'm here to use haha now we are
de lama before you were not llama but
now now we are de llama
hmm circle of life baby circle of life
changes things doesn't it isn't it
interesting how that happened would you
like a friend ha ha
too bad you shouldn't have become zombie
dude that's gonna cut beat that's gonna
check out he's hitting me oh he doesn't
like you why why you don't like me I
made you home because you smell like
fish just for fun just for fun okay we
have to harvest our little Schmeichel
ashmac oh yes for now it's looking witty
yes any more iron yeah yeah I have it
sorry I took it off you come Oh bleep
blop get down you burn just don't ask
okay thank you okay
keep it in freezing water we are farming
we're doing epic progress we should
probably start making a
stable a staple yes of course stable
stable maybe a little house for blip
blop um flip-up deserves this plop
replay on people people people are bleep
up the pub is the god of micro blip blip
blop made this game leap blah blah blah
I don't like that you have like a
feather or something in your blah blah
blah blah like it's a little prison
it's actually quite do you think he
likes it let's ask him you like it he
turned back he turned you know like you
know it's okay we give you private home
cinema soon we're working on home cinema
its next new to Minecraft is new update
here clip-clop a potato do not have
feather no you're Irish Fox take it
don't snore it swore it's Fox so he took
it ah I don't make him Irish give me PO
Oh bleep I won't be fair my boss only
he's very cute I like you a lot let me
take this feather because you do not
need it let's put these away wait we've
any more room for seeds or we awful yeah
there's a few little slots yeah should
we sort out our inventory somewhere I
feel like it's where you overdo yeah
he's a mess should we start putting
stuff how to put stuff into it okay well
let's start making a way to enter how
about we go here and then we go here and
then we go here and then we go here do
you like I like the straw as method it
work away it's the coolest way to enter
a pyramid from underground
that's how yeah but there's only one
entrance and that's where we keep the
smoke unless we move the smoke a little
further up you know Bing is he speaking
language of odd yes okay I know this is
sacrilegious but oh very sad now don't
accidentally put the campfire in the
nether they don't like it there deluca
Berkey
just making noises at this point well
YouTube is you make noises and you hope
some of them are funny and then you hope
everyone else thinks they're funny too
yeah that's the real rare oh yeah the
campfire break so touch right yes you're
trying to push me out no I'm trying to
give you a back rub
ah thanks brah you know dude bros help
Bros Bros help bros just like gamers
help gamers we should spell out the ship
shop in our firm that's smart
can't can looks like a P so I'm gonna
say it's a beauty firm Wow
thanks brah the problem you can be our
farmer or Swedish people good powers oh
yeah we love potatoes you do yeah of
sweet Irish tater whoa you really hurt
all I know keep telling people but no
one believes you no one believes me I
don't oh my god don't act upset you
pushed me I didn't I wasn't even near
you you are literally pushing me get me
a campfire put your pants on me I will
hurt you I have to challenge you now I
have to defend my honor
Oh try it I wear don't look at this blue
blob are you are you playing dirty with
love you love me most right the club no
don't bribe he's bright before he took
potato I get ya it is the cooler with
the thing at the bottom actually I see
it now maybe we can actually do like a
entrance on the side maybe that's really
dumb but I'm gonna try it you know as
long as it doesn't ruin the ergonomic
shape
oh the ergonomic shape of course of
course yes this is the power of the
pyramid the triangle is the strongest
shape I need together melibea stern
there's 64 in here
she's more than 64 that's it okay
markiplier I'm doing that voice I'm sick
I can't help it I think Mexico take all
the time I knew it
wait here I did the cobblestone was
within all a lot of you can minecraft
Wow
yeah you just hold pb4 pew I plant tree
down here fill hole with can you feel
hole in heart never I've been playing so
much minecraft to try and fill that hole
that's within but there will never be a
block fill the hole in his heart there's
no heart shaped blocks my Krishna okay
my little plan was that we have one side
that is like doesn't follow the symmetry
I know
blasphemy I know but it would just be
one little hole oh can you later holy
boy and everyone like tiny little hole
you what's there yeah upstair I just
wouldn't earn cobble cobble Club perfect
bow Hey there you go how did you manage
to put one in upside down hey guys this
one upside down yeah I was just thinking
it will look better we can't get in
unless we destroy one of the box this is
fine can't get in like that though
unless you make this a trap door man you
mean in me that's fine see that's that
doesn't look bad to me no oh you can see
the nether portal through it I do it
looks cool looks like a spaceship now
and it does RI 900 almost nighttime
typed asleep okay sheep sleep good night
flip-flop you love me right night-night
gamer can give you slime to play
look at that chat he's got slime in his
mouth yeah ha ha I wish house is mine
sleep sleep sleep tup everyone's like
wait no I just got that catchphrase that
I wanted to write in the comments ship
shopping blip blop PewDiePie
jacksepticeye you are as deep wait is
our friend she can still hear you gotta
thought
good morning chicken but the friend is
going to you friend is no more all right
it happens the best of gamers friend
said sayonara what's next on the
chopping block
well we moved the chest inside I think
good morning game idea
[Laughter]
no she move our beds in there as well
yes so we can sleep together and go blip
blop I move bit you know when you're
almost fall asleep at that's sleepover
and then someone goes blip blop and
you're like not like minecraft in sleep
sleep hey wait where do we put their
chests then we should put chests like
all the way around on the inside of this
that will be not enough storage maybe
here ok the beds next to the fire sleep
get smoked out for the same time we need
to make a new campfire ok I'll make one
I steal this one as well
maybe we'll break but now we have
charcoal Oh what else you need wooden
sticks and now we jump over the fire on
each other's beds no it's just a game
mom do we put a trapdoor over it still
um no that's kind of creepy
it is poopy but not snooping ok let's
just start moving stuff
it doesn't block it off this stroke too
strong Bruce it ah who's attacked Bruce
it for fun
mmm chip-chop do you want to live inside
o
little post e for you don't walk in fire
though it's burn it burn feel good we
need a name for the pyramid
what's our pyramid gonna be called big
pyramid mmm dinner pyramid oh there's
one block and I'm sorry don't forget to
replant trees otherwise otherwise we'll
never find anymore in Minecraft hey I
just wanted to make fun of you a little
everyone else is like Oh beauty boy
number one on YouTube and I'm like I
knew that boy since he was in diapers
man oh no that's impossible impossible
this feels like home it's just like ah
does anybody enjoyed this series I am me
me me I have good time
I wonder if or the only ones then
episode episode hundred everyone was
like I hate this new thing oh my god you
made so many stairs before ya even
realize power of gamers game I can't put
it together unless I have pictures okay
picture frames
it's called item frame but yeah we all
know real gamers know what real gamers
know it is much like if you all by the
merch by the merch gamers it's coming
along nasty it's the word you're looking
for
epically or is everything for you
epically now getting married in
Minecraft epically cool hey
he literally text me today I'd be like
Minecraft and I was like you know it you
know it go how do you normally sort
items maybe wood wood stuff can be in
here
yeah I've like block or earthy things
metal things and then
things okay blocks in here in micro
there's no blocks a micro sorry for all
the walls trololo dude don't get me
started with a troll oh yeah you know I
just can't stop you know I think all our
villager died or just died epically and
my family yeah today we have anyhow I
think there's zombie rain might have
done a thing or two
sorry there's so many oh what a
slimeball but we can bring back the one
you know we populate the earth yeah
bleep you okay chicken chicken are you
okay chickens okay chicken is fine
chicken can't swim or fly so I don't
really know why he's here how is he like
him his feathers get wet but he just
keeps on truckin okay so crafting stuff
maybe we should have like right away
here it's tough in here already oh
tippy tippy tippy tappy my flippy
floppies tippy top in my laddies keeps
your last place I mean considering how
those yeah futures gonna be they need
morning minecraft you have gaming week
to turn into a gaming millennium it
would be read in history books and this
is how a gaming week became gaming
millennia this is how the PewDiePie
effect changed gaming forever
Piplup Piplup pip it started going what
do you think he meant when he said blip
blop now I think his relationship with
his dad was very different at this time
of his life so he probably had some
impact we don't know yet what full
extent the influence it's not so much
about what he was saying it's about what
was left unsaid read between the blobs
Oh sleep time
sleep sleep time first baby sleep guys
smash like if you're excited for a new
dad there's mummies in there but sleep
there's nearby nearby I'm in there by
who nearby who want death who want the
taste of you who want taste of cold hard
steel I don't see anybody
here's speeder yeah
could it be underneath whoa minecraft
minecraft' more like mine alone
but we need to sleep if we don't sleep
phantom come and steal my pocket change
but I definitely hear him there is okay
monsters nearby where there's no like
gaps in our pyramid so you can't like
spawn in the middle of it I keep the
troll where are you cowards usually they
have to be quite far away like really
nearby yeah what the frig
oh it's it was bleep blood no well I
guess no sleep sad no sleep tonight no
sleep this is confusing me dude Pistons
does not belong here
oh I thought it was a block oh my god
you disrespect my you put dirt in yeah
dirt is a block yeah but in there no
it's minecraft you just let flow take
your hippie attitude and get you out of
my set okay can I put I may I put
buttons in the wooden one wooden buttons
yeah wouldn't buzzing put oh my god
organize what is why I'm a disorganized
person you don't love me for my
organization yeah I hate you for it
do you just love me for my scrappy go
get em attitude
they're worse oh my my bed head this
will never last Jack never lies we need
more item frame I'm taking custody of
leather and sticks sleep love look away
look at murder time or what we about to
do cow locked in my sights
blip blop I'm sorry Cal you give me one
let just something wrong I need ya for
one but you need more I'm not a friend
for bleep blood we need to sleep sleep
this is not working we have to find this
super spider spider it must be here it
must be here
I hear it maybe it's bugged I think so
I read you unless we left a gap
somewhere that they're just randomly
spawning in but spiders aren't like
four-by-four found it where was he below
if there's okay
there's a hole in the floor no just
torches in it
thank God now we can sleep that's part
of our mind oh I see
sleeps up sheep is happening without me
how am I gonna bond with friends if I
can't sleep over with them babe I'm
sleeping hey Jack
oh my god is it epic what are you
dreaming of I'm sleeping with my ho oh
you can't do that you just got married
kids stop won't step man gamers just do
it tourney like that don't they let me
sit do it dirty like that
oh yeah Enderman I see another Enderman
hey teleport where you going with those
scare boy I love fighting Enderman in
this game you're a brave man the combat
in this game is surprisingly satisfying
yeah it's not too complicated but big
it's like your brains canary Souls kind
of thing yeah you can resist them all
and dodge iframes and you can use
potions the boss is like the winner of
the boreal valley the ender dragon oh my
gosh frost please copy and crab oh my
god haha epic prank epic prank oh dude
gamers are just crazy now stop this
gamer attitude should I destroy the
houses no how do we put your epic stuff
in here that we didn't bring yeah but
definitely mom break passes now I'm
afraid to put things in different boxes
cuz you're gonna yell at me like yeah I
will yell at you organize think about
how you have your own man oh it's it's
dreadful it's really bad think of
organization and then think of opposite
of that oh my god you mean a mess
Simon's no opposite organization
that's stupid um people are gonna find
this pyramid in like 3,000 years
Wow potatoes never expire they don't
they'll ask for they're still delicious
my god you put a little cheddar cheese
in that jacket potato and there's just
gucci mane okay makes sense to have all
the block related stuff on the right
side and like maybe all the crafting the
related stuff on the right don't put a
stick in the frame if it's wood Jesus
Christ wouldn't block just too much like
all the other blocks oh well you want to
put in just like oh look here's a wooden
block huh you're a dog you make me sick
you make me want to rip okuu make me
want to sodoku dude oh so you want to
have a relaxin time I understand Sudokus
not relaxing purely someone who's never
played Sudoku well I guess you're not a
gamer then huh dude I've been too busy
dropping in for today dude
alright I'm not judging even though no
one drops on for day anymore cuz it
sucks
people drop in Minecraft what's going in
this one how do you put I don't know I
don't know I haven't figured everything
out maybe monster related stuff like
strange no jack doesn't do anything in
this series yeah cuz Felix yells at me
when I do anything different people said
yeah I'm gonna jump off this pier please
don't do it guys to leave nice coming to
jacket otherwise I love precipitate oh
yeah one of these days I'll make a
cobblestone generator and prove you all
wrong huh we should have a redstone box
as well here maybe redstone on its own
yeah I don't want to just why you got a
problem this just means that we need
more chests then we have it a turn right
stone into block this place have levels
yeah that'd be cool should be if you put
up like slabs across the middle of it
like where I am yeah right above the
Portland yeah except then we can have a
room for our bookshelves in stem yeah we
can have a summoning chamber right in
the middle and we can put power of the
pyramid it's ergonomic and channel's the
sun's energy and God's power into the
ergonomic shape a relaxed
okay no fun man's out every Super Series
let's play toy yeah yeah this is iron
horse armor where do we put that I
usually put it in the Treasury chests
that you can play with sure he can
oh you want a good bag oh I was
literally in the middle of moving it and
then it disappeared off the screen
look I just shift clicked it in and then
it had to go somewhere else on its own
all right excuse you're scaring blah
you're scaring me we put what did you
put all the metals oh here I put two
nugget nugget biscuit nugget in there is
good no good no you have stuff like
gunpowder and charcoal where did they go
we can put those stuff in barrels Maya
agrees can you hear her Maya she's gone
a little psycho lately she just starts
barking at anything that's because she
knows that you took mercy away from her
Oh artsy as hers no more what is this
shell Berg baby I hate it tell Maya
sounds apart yeah egg is like aa brush
that's amazing abre crash remember when
everyone's pets had voices on YouTube
what do you mean everybody who had a dog
or something I always make do let's do
it I know I'm saying but there's like a
time on YouTube when everyone's pets had
like aah hey what's up it's me the dog
of their YouTube channel baby like and
then somehow it became every time I saw
Edgar it's not like it's like he's a
real person he is a real person what are
you talking about now sound yeah wake up
T me the caladium ah okay I don't know
Oh Tobias Tobias we do we need a lectern
you want one you want villager yeah we
can no no you give to the zombie one and
he'll give us zombie discount yes give
it to something so much like Cartman
yeah
yes I feel like this is the first
episode we actually try hard yeah I like
it it's just pure focus and discipline
get it
it's gonna be sweet once it's all done
you know what minecraft could do with
backpacks they do I don't know they say
they do when you beat the game better I
don't when you beat the game I need more
inventory space yes when I'm on the move
don't need it when I beat you up tip oh
hello neighbor
come on this is where I keep my stare a
good oh my god
you steal my bed leave my bed it's my
bed I'm running away a heron left and
took the bed I hit you with bed Oh empty
maps pillow fights we have bed fights a
bed ready okay that that's enough
horsing around but there's a bed okay
because we don't need maps what does it
smell like that's good can you smell my
breakfast taters
yeah you're not far off okay good night
[Laughter]
that's skinny man when we beat the ender
dragon we should just place to bed
single sleep sleep sleep at the end
portal it looks like there's a chimney
for that I was literally just thinking
yeah it doesn't look good I'll remove it
I usually put gunpowder and charcoal and
all that good stuff together good call
oh yeah keep putting beds just put beds
on the entire thing
but put a bed over here maybe maybe
somebody else wants to sleep for the
night what if we get yes you never know
we put it in the chest and then jumped
out ready to place it
big brain you know how a blackboard has
a singularity per century yes
that's what my brain is right now
singularity break
do you remember syrup sandwiches dude I
used to have served sandwiches and crime
allowances maybe a farm here on the side
yeah it's pretty even here already yeah
this works good um how do you want cows
sheeps cheep cheeps I go find Oh
nifty Irish people are natural shepherds
is that true
watch this I'm gonna come back with like
a hundred and fifty cows okay we don't
even need to breed them or whatever need
to do that that's great I don't hear me
Oh special land mammals I believe when I
see you're going to be ashamed of your
words and deeds Oh Rosie's hello hello
cow it's me friendly Irishman that's
friendly I'm super friendly I'm
aggressively nice cow no that's wall
come this way top of the mornin come on
ding ding ding ding ding dong ding a
ling ending i want to do it in a way
that we get a bunch of horses and then
we put a minecart at the end and then
you get the horses to pull you in the
minecart like a sled and then call
yourself Santa Claus
has anyone done that yet I don't know
hope so that's be some sort of flying
mod Christmas special I mean we're in
the Spruce now please Jack saw I'm
asking you good you shouldn't have
brought this off you know I'm they're
gonna get it Oh much better did they get
it so claimed no you can't claim they're
gonna get it yeah it's public domain now
at this point once it becomes a meme you
lose all copyright that's oh that's why
we make no money off youtube anymore we
had so many good things going for us
and then you people at home you mean
this you frickin Fricks come on in
little Xiao Zhi Wow jeez can you find me
you know
kzv hello hello I am here hello okay not
in a million years I would now frick
Baroness how do I do they owe that and
people keep telling me to do that but it
looks over it doesn't look great but
it's very one Seagate like once you have
it you're like now I'm not doing a game
I think it navigable bag people also
said that you can put torches in a block
underground and then put carpet over it
and it still works so you can make
Lovelace oh that's cool all right so did
we kill him me for another parent or
night just kill whatever you want to
killed man don't let anyone tell you
differently we got two item frames epic
sweet back into the corner we'll be back
for more don't worry why is the big man
so scary
see now we have annoying things like
compass where do we put a comp redstone
that's right Stan
what do we get so much kelp yeah it was
when I was what are you dolphin what you
never know dude you changed it I did
it's weird now it's not the same if they
changed Sidney play minecraft and it all
goes to your head bleep blop blip blop
Omega big brain I remember PewDiePie
played amnesia my favorite videos go
back to that will you
where did we put food oh it's here
alright this time I will go out a bit
and get them cheap copies should I move
our fox into the pyramid maybe yeah I
kind of feel bad that he's just sitting
out here alone yeah he shouldn't be all
alone he's scared but the last time I
tried to move a fox bad things happened
because the leash is like to break if
you try and get foxes upstairs or
anything with a li show upstairs
sometimes it just keeps bouncing and
then you take the leash off and it
counts it oh listen
right like don't even worry about it if
anything bad happens just know it's
entirely your fault and I would hold it
against you for everything
okay I don't bring him in you stay there
oh god it's getting dark
and it opened up my eyes oh you're in
spooky zone this place is gonna be the
bomb bro the counts are gonna be here
everyone else is gonna be there it's
gonna be calm Bob calm down
[Music]
should we keep the pyramid like this or
should we started putting a top on it or
you want it to stay flat on top or these
are the top and right questions always
have the hardest answer that's the power
of the pyramid just depends on how much
time we want to do the kids well we
don't need more space right now you know
what I mean
I feel you I feel ya man it would look
pretty dang epic from a distance if it
was just small too big we should build
it like that one prism angel in Neon
Genesis yes you know I'm saying I have
to watch the show but I watched all the
movies so technically I watched the show
what's the main character's name blop
blip blop blip blop because he is the
most annoying anime character I've ever
seen in my life this is a kid who wants
to be left I know it's the problem just
fight things dude I think that the
movies just portray him a lot more
Hawaii
there's no exposition well there is but
just not enough so it's just like oh my
dad doesn't like me and I like grow up
do you know what's dads like them just
me just you blip blop blip blop you'll
be the next big pilot then wanna know
what if ratings ohh Enderman and to kill
a Enderman more like lame man we're like
we'll end you man Oh brah fight back
my sonic coward do something do
something about it oh yeah I remember
when dude I have an arrow in my toe
how did this happen man Beauty I'll do
anything to gain a few inches on people
hey I made one eye of ender in my
playthrough through it and it
disappeared immediately oh I don't know
if it actually vanished or if it broke
or anything but it did not lead me to a
stronghold oh I know are you doing
nothing what are they walking on get
back here police
you can't keep getting away with I need
leather I got desperate I'm sorry to
even get leather from the babies are you
doing placer is going off the rails
everything's exploding everything's
changing uh where do we put the woolly
wool what do I have pink wool I usually
have a one chest for a wall because then
I deem you will schist I think now we
could actually tame horses because we
have wheat and sir
oh I keep having these saddles Sado how
do you find them it's just chests if you
can find like a desert temple I find
saddles and those before or shipwrecks
is it time to explore Jackie boy think
so I think I need a lot more food if
we're gonna do that this is why I
inverted those cows Jack this is my boat
in the wood why is it not there it's not
no you have bought in oh no we moved it
because you were like oh I like boat and
minecart in different one
put it whatever the heck you want Jack
you know that's fine it's fine
the pigs like cooked potatoes everyone
should like cook potatoes if they don't
can you bring some potatoes and come to
me and then we can bring the pigs in
because pigs are really epic to the
right of me
oh there you are right if the pyramid
could mean anything makes every boy he'd
like potato yeah they like potatoes so
you should be friends
wait pigs eat potatoes in this game yeah
I've never had to herd pigs now pigs are
great for food pigs are friends yeah I
found this one too
come on follow the Irishman he will take
you to safety and don't look at me Oh
God they get distracted come on pigs
good lord
come on curly tail hey I'll be I have to
be bad cop a dumb pig okay I bring these
guys guys don't look don't look there's
nothing happening over there you don't
want to know how sausages are made
ladies you're gonna say sows game you
shouldn't know how Sasuke's made you
know how by having a rivalry with
I've never even watched why not what
what we want you now I know
Emmie look at ya ever had a chance to
watch it as a team and then how old was
like I know there's too much of it yeah
yeah totally
okay pigs I don't have fence so oh okay
replaced or replaced or do it did you
feed them the potatoes oh they must
freak
the word is in bad action okay it works
okay potato lovers okay I can only do
two that's all right you're gonna have
to love yourself you should learn love
yeah we have a lot of potatoes here
actually from my potato food yep and I'm
cooking some right now dog ah you can
boil them you can grill them you can
chip shop yeah eat them raw you can chop
them up into chips chips you can make
them into crisps whichever one is which
that's up to you bro that's
region-specific
you can throw them at someone you can
bribe people with them the police love
potatoes that's why people call them
pigs because they love potato okay whole
circle I'm done done potato damn you're
cooking a lot of potatoes Abra yeah blue
don't was great
don't go : how dare you we'll get more
to know if we do a roof there all right
it's whatever well maybe we can just
have like it go through that might be
cool like not cover everything huh
should just do like a cross yeah that
might be big brain man keep one hole in
the middle for the smoke we do need the
power of the pyramid so that makes sense
mm-hmm block off the Chi we can't get up
the stairs then to get to the next level
no Oh Frank looks cool so do it
I can I can I can climb the stairs from
the chests all right
daddy brick what did you do nothing I
felt I felt scared me sorry
that's something happened all you were
hurt I was boom you know when you hit
Appling bone sounds so satisfying right
sleep can't sleep I'm busy building keep
building I sleep yeah dude this is
awesome can you see it can you see my
brilliant masterpiece I'm sleeping so
wherever you're from it's either a cross
or an X we see what I mean now we can't
get look can't you remove this oh yeah
oh yeah keep going son keep going my dad
ever handball Wow say loan singham bro
don't forget the most powerful shape is
the pyramid and beyond that x ooh
where's that dumb block it's here isn't
it okay so I will have to mine it when
fall it no never mind
[Laughter]
wow you took such a huge risk
look at it look what we made boy make
more babies see it in your little face
okay horse time temple time we should go
on adventure time it's your friends for
once I have enough food
next episode question mark yes shop
episode they're cheap shop blip blop
blip blop blip blop see you next episode
people blip blop you're the most
important character in this whole life
yeah I play dice over series is over
there's over connect gamers smash like
subscribe well you haven't tried to
person later today after 50 million out
routes by ash
oh yeah nah go just now it's still
relevant just download it